whether whether you want to call it
societal programming or you know
subscribing to a female first primary
social order whatever it is that you
want to hear it's all the same stuff
societal programming is the belief that
is has basically gotten you to where
you're at there's a lot of guys who's
that dude Nicholas the hell was his name
there was a whack-job about 10 years ago
that shot up a school he was a
good-looking kid and he did some videos
in his BMW kind of kind of creepy you
know like it's really really really we
were to meet some of you guys if there's
somebody that knows that the guy's name
in the comment just mention it there but
um this guy was like going on about how
I'm a good-looking guy and I Drive a BMW
why can't I get the girls and it's like
he believed in societal programming you
know he believed it in a blue pill myth
the soul-mate myth Elliott Rogers that's
it thank you you know you can go look
him up but you know he he basically
believed in this blue pill myth that if
you just be yourself the girls will come
that if you just do what you've been
told your entire life then you will get
the girl and if you've been fed a steady
diet of Disney movies watching sitcoms
on TV where guy like the father like the
guy that supposed to be the head of the
household is the butt of all jokes and
the wife makes fun of them all the time
and never makes fun of them the kids
make fun of them and you think I'll just
be a loof dork and I'll get the girls it
doesn't work that way
women want strong masculine virtuous men
that are competent that can get [ __ ] dot
they want men that are dangerous but
civil that's what they want they don't
want you know sulking wimps that are
throwing money at these thoughts on
Twitch and cash you know send me cash
apps and all that sort of stuff these
guys are they're just dorks you know
they're just losers and they're going to
get bad results at life if they
subscribe to societal programming you
know if they subscribe to things like
you know the isms that I mentioned
earlier feminism liberalism globalism
socialism all those things women don't
throw themselves at guys like that they
don't they'll they'll they'll perhaps
you know take in these betas you know
the
maybe take them in as you know providers
you know to use the beta bucks component
of the hypergamy you know train you got
alpha C and beta needs sort of thing
they'll use them for that and then these
guys will cry when they wonder why the
girls are not you know sticking to them
and they're just using them for either
attention or maybe money or you know
something even less you know women will
go cry in the shoulders of these guys
that believe on societal programming you
know and then watch her run off and go
and bang mr. exciting societal
programming if it's not getting you good
results
you just have to unplug from it and go
and see the truth for everything see you
you know see it for what it is
that's what TRP really is you know
that's what the red pill you know really
is it's it's not just for the girls this
is about life this is about seeing the
political environment this is about
seeing employment this is about seeing
lifestyle choices where you're gonna
live it's not just about women that's
what it is it's about unplugging from
lies and seeing the world for what it
truly is and again you don't get good
results you're gonna end up with a guy
like Eliot Rodgers and your BMW still a
handsome kid but because you're a dork
and you believed a lot of lies that were
cramped I mean you drink a steady diet
of kool-aid lies you know you get drunk
on that kool-aid don't be surprised if
you don't get great results out of life
and you're not making money you don't
have women you know competing to be with
you it's not that difficult when you
size up and listen to all of these
things that I'm telling you here I'm not
telling you these things here to
disparage or to you know to kick anybody
if they're down I understand a lot of
people come here looking for answers and
looking for help with what they're stuck
on sometimes you guys don't like the
message sometimes you don't like the
delivery that's fine I don't care I
don't need to pander to anybody okay
it's it's not who I am I just point to
the cold hard truth hi bomber command
cold hard truth bombs coming at you
tonight fellas so don't believe in
societal programming that does not serve
you that's not aligned with winning and
that's and that's what
that's something that every guy needs to
get good honestly dudes my entire
channel there's like 600 plus videos
they're all free you don't need to join
my community you don't there's like you
don't even have to watch the premium
content that's behind the paywall
everything on my channel covers
dispelling the societal programming lies
you know the kool-aid that you guys have
been drinking that you're drunk on
that's gotten you bad results don't get
mad at it don't get mad at the content
as soon as you start getting mad at the
content and then going off block killing
yourself guess what dude you lost man
you have to just accept it you have to
surrender to the reality of the world
okay or you can go back and plug in and
you know believe the societal program
that's fine